[Applause]
I appreciate it thank you very much I
know why you're happy because the
president Donald Trump is home from his
trip to England and Ireland and France
there now fumigating Europe Wow this
week you know he went over there was the
anniversary of anniversaries this week
the 75th anniversary of d-day but also
this week hundredth anniversary of women
getting the vote in America or as
Republicans call it d-day right you got
to get right with the women's issue boy
boy Joe Biden you see that did a real
flip-flop on the abortion thing you know
the Hyde Amendment which is like you the
federal government will not pay for
abortions he was always for that now
he's against that Roe vs. Wade he said
he was always for but he's Catholic it's
complicated Joe's old-school
he believes conception begins when a guy
smells a woman's hair
also Mike Pence's birthday today he blew
out the candles and mayor Pete turned
into a pillar of salt
I don't know what
if there was groaning you should leave
now because it's gonna be a little show
for you people very rough joke but no
it's Pride weekend here is it traffic
was crazy I think it's all over the
country it's certainly here in LA you
know this is true in Boston a group of
guys got together and they want to have
a straight Pride Parade this is coming
from a group called super happy fun
America I cannot think of a gayer name
and but you know I always want to say to
people like this you know Gay Pride is
you know a response to being shamed how
can you really have a straight pride
because no one has ever shamed you you
know it's like wanting a welcome home
party when you've never left the couch
but I'm trying to put off talking about
the story that depressed me all week
more than any which is Donald Trump
overseas England's royal family met
America's royal [ __ ] and Trump
continued the time-honored condition to
the tradition he has now started of
embarrassing this country in every
possible shape form and way possible
first team he drags his whole family
over there we just say that that they
all even Tiffany really
Eric Don jr. I know what we're all
thinking the same thing how did they
ever get time off from their jobs he's
just he's just such the ugliest American
ever he gets over there he insults the
Mayor of London right away
loser you know it's um princess Megan
says she's nasty
and then the worst he mistook the Queen
for Stonehenge
[ __ ] them to [ __ ] the royal family I
hate those [ __ ] but it's just you
know you if to bow your highness another
human being I'm supposed to call your
highness don't talk to her unless she
talks to you first call back the only
reason I think they keep the Royal clam
it's good for tourism I've been to
Buckingham Palace it's not good doesn't
look like but fits like a zoo people are
like oh maybe they'll come out today
look the whole the whole point of this
trip to England in Europe was planned
around the fact that yesterday was June
6th 2019 this day will never come again
this is the 75th anniversary of d-day a
real day that honors the sacrifice of
the greatest generation and all of
Europe gathered yesterday to remember
how armies of the free world came
together to fight a common enemy
bette midler that's right while they
were doing that Trump was tweeting about
but a washed-up psycho see that's why
Donald Trump is the new Churchill
because he opened up a second front in
the war on Rosie O'Donnell it sucks that
on a day honoring America's best we sent
America's worst and his knowledge of
history history economics and science
all on great display at a moment like
this he said while we honored the people
of d-day for in Europe from Nazi control
it would have been much more easily
handled by tariffs so you didn't know if
he really said that that wasn't Joe
would have said that and the most
galling thing of all is that his own
service or lack of came up and he spit
on the graves a betty was walking
through by saying that Vietnam he said
it wasn't a fan who was so far away but
I would have been honored would have
been honored on the luck there weren't
any Wars going on at the time in the
sixties nevermind anyway but in Trump's
defense he did see action in the
trenches of studio 54 he was the guy in
charge of defending the VIP room from
the bridge-and-tunnel crap
you